but if you were to pick a person off a
rack right and pick any mental
affliction that you could an attempt to
make them immune from criticism this is
what you would pick thank you
well hold on a second she's autistic so
she can't speak well she's
manic-depressive she has anxiety so she
may not be able to perform and she has
selective mutism so she won't answer
your questions hmm
also antiphon so she might throw a
bottle at your head so I want to tie
this into why everything wrong with
credit tune Berg why she's just do
you're just the worst I'm not gonna say
anything that could get me banned she's
just the pits let's give some kind of
16-year old obviously greta toon burg
for those of you forget she is
continuing to make headlines this week
for being the favorite we don't know
right now the time of this taping the
Nobel Peace Prize
so she nominated for her outstanding
work and just just honestly fantastic
yeah Oh excellent
on the climate change stuff you know all
that business and she spoke this week at
the ongoing extinction rebellion protest
which is this thing I guess in London
here you go and we will never stop
fighting we will notice though fighting
for this planet and for ourselves our
futures and for the futures of our
children and grandchildren
that's my dad dad is one of the clowns
from Rob Zombie's by the way hit the
notification bell please do subscribe at
mug Club lot of CARICOM slash mug Club
69 students 6 $10 for students veterans
active military you get the blaze
catalog now you have Dave Rubin if the
only thing to keep this available for
free on YouTube and there's like 80%
more content there episodes every single
day you just see a small clip here and
that's do check in though every day on
YouTube because we're not in suggested
videos if you search us we don't even
show up but if you check back every day
there's always a new video at 9 o'clock
Eastern o'clock East and then eight
o'clock livestream alright here's
another point about gratitude burger I
guess I guess it's kind of a hybrid of
the Nobel Peace Prize yeah let's go back
to why gratitude burgers just the pits
for one it's innocent this isn't her
fault she's a child
Yeah right we're Toma giving away a
price now listen I'm not I'm not saying
please let me be clear I'm not saying
that we should never listen to young
people like David Bowie and such like I
get it these children that you spit on
as they try to change their well I'm not
saying that you should never listen to
young people I think that we can learn a
lot from you I really do but allowing
them to dictate policy yeah I mean this
is my biggest problem here is that they
use these children as human shields get
immune to from criticism right they did
it with David hog and let me tell you
this Republicans do it too yeah I at
CPAC remember I had to introduce a
Jonathan Crone it was like the
conservative how do we pronounce this
their weight as it was a wunderkind
wunderkind yeah that's I always hear
wooden duck in we're mayor it's like
we're just like Spanier really I'm sorry
for the bleep button um but Republicans
Jonathan Cahn remember I got into
trouble because I was talking about it
on red-eye and I said you know I think
it's I'm always uncomfortable with the
12 year old sort of Alex B Keaton
look-alike because I think they're
really parroting what their parents are
telling ya to say and there's a very
strong likelihood that you will end up
being a pot-smoking hippie at Berkeley
yeah I was right about all of it except
he went to Columbia
and then there was there was another I
can't member simm there was there was a
young black conservative who was making
the rounds wanted to be I think we had
him on once but then he was supporting
Ted Cruz and he was supporting Bernie
Sanders and then he went back to Trump
liked it there is a lot of wow I don't
want to say grifting but the thing is
like there is in open Avenue to push the
gimmick of being young and a lot of
politicians could you say their opinions
aren't developed yet yes they're not by
the way you can have print you can be a
person who already has established your
values like these aren't all that
different for when I was 14 or 15 or 16
right but you shouldn't be given a
national platform I know certainly don't
think you should be allowed to dictate
policy international policy right when
you have yet to make income but yeah
you're right they really are holding
such they're immune to criticism just
watch this leftist lose his mind at the
slightest criticism of grid Attenberg
you're a grown man and you're attacking
a child shame on you she's trying to get
leverage right am i right
relax skinny boy okay you're just gonna
act this because I banged your mom
[Laughter]
person who could run and defend himself
just calm down all right man who has a
40-yard dash that would be competitive
at the combine you're not fit to hold
greta's braid let's compare that with
the treatment of if you remember the
covington children swift backlash
against the behavior of those Kentucky
teens travel to Washington this past
Friday on a school trip to attend the
March for Life the Diocese of Covington
Catholic High School where some of the
boys attend condemning their actions
saying in a statement this behavior is
opposed to the Church's teachings of
dignity and respect the matter is being
investigated and we will take
appropriate action
up to and including expulsion means the
behavior of simply standing there
smiling while they're being berated by
Brack Blackie Brack sorry that's a
little bit of hot black Hebrew
Israelites in real light what's
happening
should you be more concerned that those
kids that they weren't had sex with all
that people didn't make sex with them
like that would be my concern just
saying take an altar boy leave an altar
boy
the main difference here is that is that
um they didn't shoes when you talk about
the company they didn't show us to be in
the spot it was like well how can you I
know I actually think that you can point
out a double standard and say that one
is defensible a they didn't do anything
wrong not the grete did anything wrong
necessarily I think her opinions are
wrong I think her parents have done
something wrong but when you compare the
company kids it was someone with a phone
who took it out of context and then
their lives were ruined
Greta decided to thrust herself into the
spotlight and so I do believe that there
is a certain level of criticism which is
valid at that point you certainly
shouldn't be immune from it just because
of your age if you decided that you are
going to be the torch bearer that's just
my thought and I think yes we should be
more forgiving of children right
absolutely they make mistakes but they
don't they don't they shouldn't all get
a pass no right they shouldn't like have
a kid murder somebody like we don't try
them as an adult well you know what they
like you still Timmy let me clarify it's
this is not this is everything wrong
with the concept
this is everything wrong with the circus
that is dune burg okay not necessarily
her so another another point everything
wrong about she's she's the mental issue
can we not say mental you suffer from
mental illness I've been he's open about
it
fin Berg is diagnosed with Asperger's
syndrome also obsessive-compulsive
disorder disorder and a new one for me
selective mutism and I know what you're
thinking
selective mutism sounds like both
welcome back she was also said to suffer
from severe depression eating disorders
and panic attacks here's my question why
this is not about her I'm not condemning
her for struggling with whatever that
being what do they call it a
neurodiverse I don't know
if she's struggling on the pressure and
as someone who has struggled with
depression it's a mental illness doesn't
mean that it needs to be debilitating
but I think we should be honest about
this and I don't think we should silence
people for bringing it up I am not at
all condemning Greta for struggling with
whichever one of these afflictions she
may have but why would anyone in their
right mind use her as a political pawn
knowing that she responds so poorly to
stress this clip is sad
[Music]
and look I hate to hear that cheer she
was tough I'm sorry my brain is not
working and they cheer listen I'm sorry
if you're an adult you say I'm sorry my
brain is not my brain is not working
people don't cheer right in people I
said we'll give her a break English is
your second language she's autistic you
know what I say yes yes
English is her second language she's
autistic depressive obsessive-compulsive
has anxiety driven selective mutism
let's give her a break by not thrusting
her into an international spotlight
where she will be forced to talk with
multiple people and face justifiable
criminal criticism on a global scale
let me posit something here okay um I do
believe let me be really clear I do
believe in autism I think that
Asperger's some people say another thing
ADHD I understand yes I'm not one of
those people who thinks it's made up and
it's all in your head right selective
mutism I don't know anything about does
anyone else hear heard about that before
okay I never anything about it but I
will say about all the others Asperger's
ADHD I think we can also agree that a
lot of these issues they're overly
diagnosed and kids are overly medicated
I think the right things can be true
absolutely yes so the parents are
obviously the ones guiding the ship that
leads to these diagnoses yeah the same
parents by the way who dress her in the
ant if a flag lest you forget yes but if
you were to pick a person off a rack
right and pick any mental affliction
that you could in attempt to make them
immune from criticism this is what you
would pick thank you yes
well hold on a second she's autistic so
she can't speak well she's
manic-depressive she has anxiety so she
may not be able to perform and she has
selective mutism so she won't answer
your questions she might throw a bottle
at your point number four that's wrong
with better tune Berg is the cultism
right there's this cult of personality
maybe the most bizarre aspect to this is
their they're actually celebrating Greta
as some sort of saint oh you know we
said this for a while that the left's
new religion is just secular humanism
it's it's it's earth worship it's Gaia
its climate change alarmism right yep
we want to solve the problem kill all
people that's what it is let's consider
the context of NBC they've now launched
a website where you can confess your
climate sins well really oh my gosh a
multinational billion-dollar corporation
NBC you first how about that
how many how many people with how many
people had to develop that website when
they were drinking from aluminum redbull
cans and farts those are a thing I'm
just saying did you need to do the box
set of the office couldn't you just put
them in a manila envelope what
sacrifices you guys can make the most
right we talked about taxing the ritual
how about we talk about the people who
waste the most as far as plastic as far
as emissions space how about you confess
first and change it up now we have
op-eds they're referring to - Greta as
Joan of Arc climate activists have been
portraying her as Mary or Christ in
Sarah Silverman and yeah what was the
Sarah Silverman in blackface or not
different this was just normal Sarah's
okay I didn't see the clip Sarah
Silverman in horseface okay of Sweden
they've declared her the successor of
Jesus Christ which is odd concerned that
Silverman doesn't even believe in Jesus
Christ yeah all right I think it's a
final point your point number five we
got to get to hutch Winston yeah she's a
Greta this is one her she is a fraud the
idea what's been built around her is
fraudulent she made headlines that she
was sailing right instead of flying to
United States to avoid emissions here's
something they don't tell you her crew
not wanted her whole crew that had to
fly back Plus was producing more
emissions than it would have just taken
to fly her there in the first place
congratu you sailed across the Atlantic
on your own congratulations you get a
Peace Prize oh wait you just rode the
sailboat well the crew yes operated it I
meant flew back again all of this is a
photo op all it really is a propaganda
and then after all that of course you
ten of the UN climate change accent
summit and she filed a complaint against
five countries yeah we should get right
on that's good not among them by the way
China sorry bill biggest producer of co2
emissions I don't know who you got to
talk to there but put it in the
suggestion box yeah I don't blame Greta
I
really don't want to be really clear
here lest we be banned or for the Opera
I have no idea you know what Fair Play
I do blame the parents and the people
all people who use children as political
pawns and if anything I wish that I
could talk to Greta Greta to Greta and
and tell her that these people just like
we said this about David hog and look
where is David hog now yes people are
going to use you up Greta yeah
chew you and spit you out the end result
of political wound Durkins it perfectly
mirrors that of child stars Yeah right
the most valuable skill that Greta needs
to acquire in life right now right now
Greta if I could talk to you is it's not
confidence it's not boldness it's not
bravado
it's discernment specifically
discernment in who to trust that's gonna
be big for you sweetheart
I really don't want to see you go the
path of David hog or Corey Haim hey
there YouTube viewer if you like this
video click one of these other videos
playing in a box subscribe hit the
notification bell you may be wondering
why after this outlandish video this is
such a straight end card that's because
we've recently learned that end cards
actually determine the YouTube algorithm
as it relates to controversy on a
sliding scale so we have a yellow and it
escalates all the way to the word